welcome everyone to this webinar
in my part of this presentation i want
to briefly introduce the topics that we
will cover in the training program to
give you a sense of what kind of
activities you will be involved in what
kind of topics you might apply
bioinformatics to and how will we
structure this program and then i'll
pass it on to
another team member to talk about the
structure of each session
what is going to be covered when how to
register for the specific program and
what to expect
so
when we speak about bioinformatics uh
typically the background of the majority
of the people related to bioinformatics
is in research
and in research primarily the focus of
bioinformatics is to understand what is
in the data and link it to a specific
phenotype so so that we can characterize
a very defined process and find links to
the application
and then bioinformatics in medicine
has to do with taking that research and
applying it to
diagnose and treat specific diseases
and in this program we're going to focus
on several different diseases one of
them and a major cause of death in the
united states and around the world is
cancer
so
cancer was the second leading cause of
death
in the united states
or in the world sorry and primarily it
affects western nations but it is uh
affecting more and more developing
nations as well
and
the study of cancer has led us to
first of all kind of identify specific
genes that are responsible for different
aspects of cancer development and
progress and then eventually today more
and more studies focus on a much greater
detail of how the systems biology of
cancer
can be used to treat and
help people even by preventing cancer
so to understand cancer progression we
need to understand that
healthy cells as they develop
eventually some of them
lose
some mechanisms of restriction
that
cause
those cancers with damaged dna and all
kinds of unwanted processes to
proliferate uncontrollably and even
spread throughout the body and so when
we speak about cancer and
stages of cancer development we're
speaking about the onset of cancer when
these cells start to appear and there's
a tumor and eventually spreading
throughout the body and that is what we
call metastases
and what's important to
address this problem to really treat
cancer
a critical part of that is screening and
identifying the risky populations and
then within those risky populations to
identify the onset of cancer
and so what people have been doing to
understand these mechanisms at the
biological level is identify markers of
cancer risk
and translating those markers of cancer
risk to
strategies for screening and early
diagnosis of cancer
now a lot of that relies on modern
technologies like next generation
sequencing
and what people have found is that next
generation sequencing can allow us to
understand what happens in the cell
using the same technology but monitoring
several different critical molecular
processes inside tissues and cells
and
collectively we call these
data types generated by next generation
sequencing
[Music]
omics and these omics data can be
applied to different levels of
what happens
within the cell on aggregate for example
in a whole tissue or specific to an
individual cell and that's where we have
single cell technologies like single
cell genomics single cell
transcriptomics etc
and so when we
try to understand
how these technologies can help us
detect what's happening inside the cell
one of the ways to use is to measure
transcriptomic
transcriptomic signals and those signals
are a good proxy for what we will call
as the functional component
the proteins that are being produced
within the cell
here's a good example
in breast cancer
there is a
specific receptor on the surface of the
cell
called per2
and that receptor is responsible for
signaling that communicates with
inside the nucleus
how to produce
specific growth hormones and that is one
of the causes of this unproliferated
growth
well to measure proteins on the surface
is not very practical
and so people have used transcriptomics
to identify the gene that expresses her2
and that gene is erbb2
and by looking both at the level of
expression and alternative splicing of
that gene
we can identify potential responders to
treatment
but these kinds of strategies focused on
just a single gene have essentially been
evolving and so what we see within
different types of cancer like for
example breast cancer we are seeing that
the classification of cancer continues
to expand and it continues to expand
based on
a growing number of marker genes like
her2
and an integration between those genes
which is the molecular classification
but also multiple other factors like
even proteomics and metabolomics
and that's why we see this conversion
between research-based bioinformatics
and clinical use
of bioinformatics where this kind of
understanding of what happens at the
molecular level is actually critical for
accurate classification of an individual
patient or a group of patients but
ultimately also for selecting a
treatment that is more likely to work
and be effective for that individual
so as a result bioinformatics for
clinical use relies on
big data of various types that is
integrated and ultimately is being used
for diagnostics and therapeutics
now what's interesting is that not only
is this data being used for patients but
essentially we are seeing
a number of experiments that are not
possible on actual human patients and so
another major challenge in these kinds
of studies is to be able to
accurately represent what happens inside
the patient's body by using animal
models of human disease and so when we
will explore the role of bioinformatics
and precision medicine and examples of
bioinformatics applied to data sets we
will use both clinical samples taken
from patients but also animal models
like
patient xenograph models where a tumor
is grafted inside the animal
to study those biological processes but
also to try and
intervene using a variety of compounds
and that essentially leads us to this uh
kind of big data paradigm in
uh molecular studies where we have
uh kind of a a an approach of
using data to inform our hypotheses
and essentially then being able to model
a specific process
and apply that process to actual
treatment of patients
and that leads to shorter discovery and
validation timeline
higher success rate and lower costs and
these are really the objectives of
precision medicine in terms of their
actual clinical use
because if we were just to take all of
the data available about the patients
and use that data for every single
individual it is just simply cost
prohibitive
but if this kind of collection and
analysis of data is informed by large
scale studies
that then can stratify patients and
determines which ones are likely to
benefit from this approach then it leads
to actual improvement in
outcomes
more efficacy but also lowering costs
overall
so in this program
we will benefit from those large studies
that have collected systematically uh
data about different types of projects
and so as you can see on this chart
the growth in the amount and
availability of data has been
exponential over the past a couple of
decades actually and today we have
access to um in smaller studies and
larger studies and one of those studies
related to cancer is called the cancer
genome atlas tcga
so what's unique about this study is
that they have been able to collect
systematically from different locations
and in different types of tissues and
cancers
a huge collection of thousands of
individuals
that comprehensively characterizes their
genomic transcriptomic proteomic and
even metabolomic profiles
allowing us to search through the
clinical data that are associated with
risk factors and outcomes and even
treatment
and determine how we can use this data
both at the clinical and the molecular
level to better understand this complex
disease so one of the studies that we
will look at is how such multinomics
integration and analysis of molecular
profiles has led to
a new understanding of complex diseases
based on multiple types of omics data
but the tcga project is already not so
new so i think it was started in 2013 so
it's been around for quite some time
what has happened since then
well more recently a new study called
all of us research has started making
their data accessible as well
and so there we have uh the objective is
to have over a million individuals that
represent both different kinds of
conditions but also help us understand
the variability of healthy individuals
so another source of data that we will
look at and we will try to see what
kinds of cohorts are available is the
all of us research hub and i think for
all of you that are coming from a
research background this is an exciting
new opportunity to try and understand
and develop preliminary hypotheses based
on this data about those topics that you
are interested in
another interesting project that we will
look at throughout this program is the
nih human microbiome project that
exclusively focuses on characterization
of metagenomic sequencing for human
microbiome both for for healthy
clinical and pre-clinical individuals
it's an exciting uh project that has
grown over the years today we have the
human microbiome project one human
microbiome project two and the project
continues to evolve with specific
focuses and actually is going to be a
part of the all of us research as well
in addition to these large repositories
we will also look at several examples of
publications that have leveraged animal
studies or cell line studies to
accurately represent patients and test
different assumptions both about about
molecular characterization of patients
but also on testing and response to
different types of treatments both those
that are already on the market and those
that are still being evaluated in
clinical trials
now when you think about all of these
different data sets and the skills that
you might need to have to address some
of the interesting questions that you
could answer with these data sets you
might feel overwhelmed and this is
understandable because there are so many
different tools and packages and methods
including statistical analysis machine
learning and deep learning it is
difficult to envision one to be able to
go through all of that
learning from scratch about the
important questions the data sets and
all of the tools
and so for that reason what our team has
done is worked with the tower
bioinformatics research center that has
developed a user-friendly version of all
of these complex algorithms that one can
learn to use and understand the logic of
analysis without being hindered by the
technical complexity of each one of
these methods so the platform offers a
user-friendly interface on this
interface there are color-coded paths or
pipelines that you can reproduce
accurately and get easy to understand
and use visual outputs that speak to the
biology that can be found in this data
included are several different pipelines
and utilities that you can use to work
with this complex data be able to
understand and mine it and especially
we will use curated data sets that allow
us to deploy standard or conventional
machine learning techniques to explore
and understand variability defining
groups of patients or
specific gene sets that can identify
individual patients
now what we'll do is we will look at
this through the lens of case studies
and we will try to use
data from the types of
studies that i already mentioned like
cancer human microbiome project or all
of us research but we will also
incorporate some ideas from the
infectious diseases where an important
trend has emerged over the past several
pandemics or epidemics in the past
couple of decades and those include such
outbreaks like ebola virus outbreak in
west africa in 2014 2016
different types of understandings of the
disease the pathogen interacting with
the host and understanding responses to
those
markers but also using microbiome and
infection which will allow us to
appreciate the role of multi-omics
integration and bioinformatics in those
kinds of studies as well
so what can you expect as a result of
going through such training
the real outcome is a project not only
will you be able to listen to lectures
from experts that will highlight some
important aspects of current and
traditional development of
bioinformatics in different applications
but you will also be able to design a
project that highlights and showcases to
the world what you are able to do with
these kinds of skills
so specifically we will talk about the
application of such tools for clinical
decision making where we will look at
such applications like patient
stratification disease classification
identification of potential responders
to therapies mechanisms of disease onset
and progression
and the way that such tools are used in
both pharma and biotech early biomarker
discovery detection of toxicity at the
in vitro stage analysis of molecular
mechanisms of a drug action and drug
repurposing or repositioning
so these kinds of topics are impactful
and can be very meaningful whether you
are a student and you would like to
demonstrate what you have learned and
how you have been able to use data to
ask and answer some of these complex
questions
or they could be useful for your
research where you're interested to get
into this field you would like to
improve your skills but ultimately you
would like to try and see how they work
in real life
throughout the program you will be given
access to some of the tools that i
already mentioned but we will also rely
on rstudio and bio python to analyze
data sets and write the code uh maybe
simply by modifying it or actually
writing it from scratch and to do that
our portal that uh sri gauri already
showed to you and you have enrolled in
uh offers a number of uh kind of guided
processes to help you understand the
link behind the logic of the analysis
the syntax of the code the different
curated data set examples that we are
going to look at and
practicing that code so that you can
ultimately become independent
and as a result of this you will be able
to
accumulate a repository of your own uh
code that you can essentially use in the
future for your own research or for
whatever situation you will come across
in your future career so here are some
learning outcomes that we envisioned for
this program i think that you will learn
to appreciate and understand scientific
literature that describes analysis of
various types of omnics data including
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
and others
you will know how to perform basic
processing steps for such data with
consistent accuracy you'll be able to
perform exploratory analysis and
generate a hypothesis from data
you'll know how to design contracts
contrasts for statistical tests and
prepare data for machine learning
you'll be able to annotate found signal
using biological databases and
references and you learn how to identify
appropriate data sets for answering a
specific biological question
as a result you will
learn and be able to plan a
bioinformatics analysis from start to
finish completely independently
and we will offer an opportunity to
present your final project proposal
including the rationale the method
scientific background and anticipated
results to an experienced mentor that
will be able to provide you with
feedback i'll finish with this
testimonial of a previous participant
her name is olgo dartsva and she was the
research affiliate a postdoctoral
student at roswell park comprehensive
cancer center what she said was that the
program is very well structured and easy
to follow
the skills that she gained through the
program helped her significantly enhance
the relevance of her research by making
connections between the pre-clinical
study and its practical application to
cancer patients
so with that i would like to pass this
on to dr mohit mizunder who will speak
about some of the program resources the
outline of the different sessions and
all of the topics that will be covered
in those sessions